[Applause]
and for the third straight game again
crunch time clutch time Denver the
better teams as they let the shot clock
run out
and a disappointing crowd obviously
Lakers heading for the locker room
and Denver is one win away from nuggets
history their magical season continues
they take the three-nothing lead here in
these Conference Finals
with an emphatic 11-point win on the
road
Anthony Davis
was strong throughout
but Denver the team down the stretch
the Nuggets now
11-3 in these playoffs
[Applause]
24 points eight assists and six rebounds
Jamal Murray another huge scoring game
with 37 but they had to help Bruce Brown
was terrific Michael Porter Jr
with some big plays
Jeff Green as well in the fourth quarter